welcome to the live stream we do have a
Bernie Sanders rally of not rally
although it may turn into one a Town
Hall coming up in just a few minutes on
Fox News this is Fox News being quite
frankly just opportunistic they know
Bernie needs help in Michigan they are
holding the rally in Detroit and we will
be watching it starting at the bottom of
the hour welcome to everybody who is
just joining us we are on the eve of
what may be either the reinvigoration of
Bernie's campaign or effectively the end
of it and I mean listen you guys know I
don't I don't blow smoke up anybody's
ass here I believe it's over for Bernie
Sanders I'm not saying I wish it were
that way I tell you things as they are I
am out I am about math I am about facts
and it just looks very very bad for
Bernie Sanders in fact I have to be
completely speculative doesn't even
really cover it to come up with a
scenario where Bernie can win but
Bernie's doing what he has to do
Bernie's doing all he can do which is
hey let's ask Elizabeth Warren for an
endorsement
let's cater to Elizabeth Warren's of
followers supporters let's do a town
hall in Michigan where people are voting
tomorrow what else can he do right so
let's look at the numbers as they are
today we have a whole bunch of new polls
and it's just ugly it is very very ugly
and I see the super chat starting to
come in over here and I am going to get
to those momentarily but we do have a
lot to discuss here we have new national
polling from this week which as you can
see let's zoom that in a little bit geez
actually that doesn't really work okay
we have Biden plus 19 nationally we have
Biden plus 16 nationally Biden plus 16
nationally Biden plus 13 nationally as
you can see here the numbers are just
overwhelming if we look at the states
that are voting tomorrow bernie is
putting everything on Michigan
everything is on Michigan and
unfortunately it is very ugly in
Michigan these are all new polls ladies
and gentlemen Biden plus 15 Biden plus
12 Biden 21 Biden 40
Biden 24 now the the bullet point is oh
whoa Bernie was down in the polls in
2016 in Michigan but he won the momentum
at that time was shifting towards Bernie
whereas the momentum now is shifting to
Biden I wish it were different I wish it
were different if you vote in Michigan
go the hell out and vote help prove me
wrong but guys I'm not going to come in
here and tell you that that Bernie has
any kind of serious shot it would take a
miracle quite frankly if we look at
Washington this one was presumed to be
okay for Bernie
the latest polls are Biden plus three
and Biden plus one maybe Bernie can eke
it out or get roughly half the delegates
there in Missouri we have Biden plus 30
and Biden plus 22 and then just Biden
plus four we'd have to see if Warren was
still included in the +4 okay maybe he
could do something there Mississippi I
don't even know that there's polling in
Mississippi but Biden might win by like
50 in Mississippi and then you know the
the thing is if you look at the delegate
count today even if Bernie can somehow
make up the 90 delegate deficit tomorrow
I think Bernie falls further behind then
you have to contend with Florida on
March 17th
Florida's 219 delegates by its very self
and Biden in the latest poll the only
one from March Biden is up 47 so do I
think Bernie has a shot in in the most
narrow technical sense sure I think it's
going to be very very tough we saw
endorsements coming in over the last 48
hours Kamala Harris endorsing a Joe
Biden Jesse Jackson endorsing Bernie
Sanders at this point I don't even know
if the Jesse Jackson endorsement does
more good than harm to Bernie and you
know that's it Oh people are telling me
Hassan is crying oh I should call guys I
know about the Hassan is correct the
people are crying meme at this point I'm
not falling for it in fact I saw Stephen
Kenneth destiny bunnell the second for
brunch last weekend and we were talking
about how people think I actually am
falling for these dumb memes but I just
pretend to be falling for them because
my audience reacts like crazy to them
but no III understand what's going on as
we are just 17 minutes away from the
Bernie Sanders Town Hall okay let me do
some thank-yous and messages and all
sorts of stuff is going on if you are
watching on YouTube you can send super
chats oh and we're not live on Facebook
let me get us live on Facebook you can
send super chats via YouTube they'll
show up in the bottom left of the screen
which is currently gray I see some
messages coming in we will get to those
momentarily if you are watching on
twitch then you can subscribe via Prime
or directly and your message will show
up in the upper right hand corner which
will be very exciting to many many
people let's get to some of the YouTube
messages that are coming in so far first
and foremost is Kevin Macomber who says
why is housing so expensive in blue
states fix well the economies of blue
states tend to be stronger and it tends
to so you went when you a state has a
stronger economy you tend to have a
higher cost of living also the the blue
states can contain most of the desirable
large cities where people want to live
desirability also increases cost of
living John McKinney says my advice to
Bernie Sanders supporters don't get
complacent that's why Bernie lost Super
Tuesday remember to get out and vote
that's the only way he'll win the
primary don't get cocky I don't know any
cocky Bernie Sanders supporters right
now III but Bernie Sanders has it listen
if you wanted me to bet on Bernie does
101 to 1 odds even get me to bet on
Bernie like white would I bet $1 would I
bet $1 to to maybe win a hundred on
Bernie I don't even know that I would
take hundred to one odds right now I
mean it's that it's it's if you you know
you tell me to put my money where my
mouth is you need to give me better than
hundred to one odds to bet anything on
Bernie I guess if you give me hundred to
one odds I throw a hundred at it right
and and maybe I win ten grand I
I don't know it would be very very tough
very very tough
ey TPS says via super chat message
deleted by T haze I don't know if that's
the super chat or if the message was
actually deleted that's interesting
though and then Casey Bates says David
do you think GOP is more serious about
the virus we're calling it the cool
virus cuz otherwise I get demonetised
now that the Florida Matt Gaetz
constituent died and Trump is likely
infected I'm sure they hope the death
percentage is low now I don't know that
Trump is likely infected but I mean
while we're doing while we're doing a
cool virus stuff you might notice that
Trump publicly insists that everything
is just totally fine this is video of
Trump refusing a handshake and doing an
elbow bump over the weekend take a look
at this and shake no and then they go
with the elbow bottle so Trump knows
right
Trump knows at this point that it's
serious Trump claims he's gonna continue
doing rallies look at his schedule there
are no rally scheduled Trump claims this
is no big deal it's like the flu
Trump check out the Vanity Fair article
I'll tell you about it tomorrow Trump
now says he's worried that journalists
on Air Force One I hope you're sitting
down
Trump is worried that journalists on Air
Force One are going to weaponize the
cool virus and infect Trump with it but
he says it's just like the flu I'm not
aware of him being worried that the flu
will be weaponized against him and then
lastly Donald Trump says this is just
like the flu except normally Trump
shakes hands and here he is not shaking
hands so it is bad it is bad
let's look at some of the latest numbers
latest number of remember this is
cumulative cases 114 thousand four
thousand five deaths sixty-two thousand
people have now recovered active cases
this is a very very important graph
active cases because the cumulative
number is going to continue rising what
you want is the active cases to decline
and as you can see they are not
declining they are going up the US isn't
even testing the numbers could be
absolutely Wow
as you can see here of scaled linearly
total cases and deaths are both climbing
almost vertically that's not good but if
we want to find something good I will
tell you what it is
China has only 44 new cases yesterday
China updates the numbers once a day and
I believe were 40 minutes from China
updating the numbers China's number of
active cases is declining by about a
thousand a day and what you'll see is
that sorted in terms of cases per
million people
China has dropped into fifth and may
soon drop into sixth or even seventh in
cases per million because China is
clearing cases very rapidly that's a
good thing now they needed six weeks of
authoritarian police state in order to
do it that's a concern one of the
biggest areas of concern right now is
Italy it's absolutely unconscionable
what is happening in Italy Iran is
having trouble after that you've got a
couple of your other European countries
South Korea South Korea what is very
important so listen I don't want to
should I even do this to you my I'll do
the ramp okay listen here's the deal
folks I sound like Joe Biden now the
death rate of 3.4 is likely very high
and there's a good piece in The
Washington Post about this this doesn't
mean Trump's doing anything right it
just means 3.4 is probably high because
a lot of that death rate is weighted to
the early cases in China okay
where they didn't know what was going on
it was chaotic if you look according to
this article at cases diagnosed after
February 1 the death rate is low when
you look at which place has been doing
testing of large numbers of people it's
South Korea South Korea has been testing
large numbers of people and when you
look at the South Korean a death rate
which is 53 deaths with seven four seven
eight cases you have a point seven
percent death rate
I'm hopeful because I don't give
whatever about the politics I don't want
people to die I want to deal with this
I have travel coming up I have family
that that is you know immunocompromised
I want the best possible outcome the one
good thing is that South Korea which has
actually been doing widespread testing
which is what you have to do do you
really want to know how many people in
the US have it I don't believe do you
does anybody believe there's 624 cases
in the u.s. of course not
there are thousands if not more cases in
the United States we're not testing the
way to test is you take an area where
you have some cases you test everybody
okay
South Korea did that their death rate is
0.7 percent the hope is the death rate
is far lower after the Wuhan initial
outbreak because we're getting better at
identifying this quarantine providing
supportive treatment even if there's no
cure that's number one number two it may
there's the idea it may have mutated
because these things mutate over several
months it's been several months now it
may have mutated into a less severe
strain this is it's possible we don't
know yet so I believe that it is
conceivable that the death rate is
actually significantly lower than this
3.4 percent we don't know but the South
Korean numbers are optimistic as far as
that goes you see that ranked by cases
per population South Korea's very high
because they're doing the right thing
and they're testing a whole bunch of
people they're just testing large groups
of people and the death rate is very low
that's my cautious optimism on this okay
let's get back to what we are waiting on
we are waiting we are just minutes from
a Bernie Sanders rally now before we get
started I do want to say just one thing
tomorrow night we're gonna have like a
5-hour stream it's gonna be absolutely
cuckoo for cocoa puffs and I hope that
all of you join me we're gonna have a
big a big thing going on tomorrow as far
as membership goes for today's stream we
have a very modest membership goal it's
just 25 new members that's it okay
you're not going to hear me talking
about it very much we're running a test
I'm gonna
talk about it very little but we'll see
if we can do it
membership is the number one funding
source for our program we keep almost
the entire payment compared to all these
other platforms that are just taking
taking taking sounds like Mitt Romney
all of a sudden and we have a coupon
code that'll save you sixty-six percent
that coupon code is twenty twenty now
everybody who signs up I will thank you
this blue bar which is embarassingly at
zero right now is going to start filling
up so consider yourself invited if you
want to do just a little something for
us with these streams grab a membership
at join pakman.com I promise you I will
thank you and it'll be a it'll be a
beautiful beautiful thing let me just
make sure that our website is not down
oftentimes the first time I mentioned it
mention it during a stream the website
implodes no the website is up very very
good and of course twitch prime subs all
of that stuff I will be thanking people
let's look at some other super chats as
we wait here
Kevin Macomber says listen here you dog
faced pony soldier yes very very good
Jason Aldridge sends two super chats one
with a question what do you see
happening Biden V Trump this 2020 listen
the stream tomorrow will start right
around 8 p.m. for people asking here's
my view on Trump or Bernie Trump vs.
Bernie and Trump versus Biden a lot of
people in my audience have very
black-and-white views on this where they
say David the only person who can beat
Donald Trump is whoever you support
right whether it's Bernie whether it's
Tulsi whether it's yang or very few
people say it about Biden because maybe
the Biden people aren't that confident
about Biden which is understandable
here's my view if the cool virus is
brought under control if the economy is
perceived to be pretty good and right
now it's it's tanking very quickly Trump
is likely to get reelected no matter who
the Democratic nominee is on the other
hand if the economy is perceived to be
poor and the cool virus is not under
control then it's very likely that
either Biden or Bern
have a shot at defeating Donald Trump
that's my view I know it's not popular
among the sort of more cultish
supporters of the different candidates
but listen I I I'm quite frankly just
too naive through at this point be even
pseudo deifying any candidate these are
just people they are flawed they have
good policies and bad policies that's it
you're not gonna hear any deification of
any candidate from from me Beezus see
Christ says not all populations
genetically similar or diverse I'm not
sure I understand but I think it refers
to the the coul virus people wondering
why I'm calling it the cool virus the
reason is the monetization if you
actually talk about it by its real name
you get demonetised on the youtubes so
we say we call it the cool virus and
that's uh that's that's sort of it
that's the full the full story let me
say just an incredible this this is
maybe the biggest thank you I've ever
done I want to say thank you to Courtney
Forrester Courtney Forrester no I'm
sorry Grayson oh I think this might be
Grayson the fourteen-year-old who
watches the show using his mom's account
Grayson Forrester is today's first new
member at join pakman.com Grayson's 14
years old folks
assuming I'm talking about the same
Grayson and has gotten a membership if
you are an adult you can certainly grab
a membership at join pakman.com and the
goal today what is that
1:01 oh I see there's a there's a typo
one of 25 new members let's uh let's
fill it up Greyson using mom's credit
card unless I'm completely miss
identifying a Grayson also I want to say
thanks to Eric harloff who is new member
number two today Eric thank you very
much appreciated let me also say thank
you over on Twitch to Shayne errs who
has gifted five community subscriptions
I appreciate that and sup DNS has
subscribed with twitch Prime which I
very much appreciate as well Beezus see
Christ says means the
death rate may be higher for different
populations I absolutely there's no
doubt about that
we may see different death death rates
for different populations no question
about it whatsoever
we do have a hype train happening on
Twitch I want to welcome plague of the
earth who has gifted two more
subscriptions and I appreciate that or
just a few minutes from the start of the
Bernie Sanders FoxNews townhall Bernie
Sanders as we talked about already
listen I I'm not gonna blow smoke up
anybody's ass or anywhere else that
smoke may occasionally be blown the odds
are probably worse than 100 to 1 for
Bernie Sanders or 1 to 100 I don't know
exactly in any case I think you guys get
the point
he's losing essentially every state
tomorrow other than he can might tie
Idaho and might tie North Dakota it's
looking very very bad so unless the
polls are so wrong that Bernie somehow
can make up a ninety delegate deficit
tomorrow it's gonna be very very bad all
right let's see what's happening with
the Bernie Town Hall here oh nothing yet
ok
well we'll get back to that momentarily
let me say thank you to a few other
people who are signing up Haroon Mohamed
Haroon Mohamed is new member number
three tonight thank you so much Haroon I
really appreciate your support at joined
pakman.com i also want to say thank you
to Brian Gallagher Brian Gallagher is
new member number four tonight at join
pakman.com you can take advantage of the
coupon code 20/20 now info is up there
you will save 66 percent which is just
unbelievable in the meantime I do want
to see if there is a YouTube stream of
this town hall let's see snooze Bernie
Town Hall because that might actually be
interesting for us but I am not seeing
that so hopefully this stream comes
alive very very soon because I don't I
don't fully know what's going on let me
just refresh we want to make sure we
don't we don't lose it
folks programming will return shortly
okay very good
all right other super chats coming in
okay Nicole oh no let's see Matt well
sir says will yang steyr and Gabbard
endorsed Bernie no idea won't make a
difference
Nicole s do you think the media's
coverage of Biden's mental decline will
hurt his chances tomorrow maybe
marginally maybe marginally Daniel
Krieger Biden will be nothing but a DNC
puppet Doug E says you should eat cocoa
puffs on stream tomorrow I don't have
any cocoa puffs but maybe otherwise I
would let me say thank you to s Doh chol
who says via twitch oh just sends it to
send some bits on twitch I appreciate
that thank you very much let's see here
other people that I wanted to thank for
new memberships no nobody else right now
and we are standing by here for the
Bernie Sanders Fox News townhall a
plague of the earth has gifted another
subscription over on Twitch I appreciate
that
estaban cifuentes says if Biden loses to
trump will the Democratic Party move
more progressive or will they put up
another moderate in 2024 mm my belief is
that if Biden loses the Trump you will
see someone more progressive in 2024 but
I know nothing I know nothing about
anything so I don't know why anyone why
anyone would would listen to me quite
frankly if this has gone live and we
have missed anything please let me know
but as far as I can see this is still
live and we are just waiting for the
stream stream to resume Bama Gus says
sessions or Tuberville will take the
Senate seat in Alabama very likely very
very likely
the only way we achieve these goals is
through a political revolution can the
Democratic socialists reignite his
revolution again with the socio by the
way I've been saying for six years he
should never call himself a Democratic
Socialist I think that has certainly
been proven true and it when you see how
North Florida Democrats go almost
completely to Biden we will all be in
agreement the Democratic Socialist thing
was not a good idea from day one then
drop there's no limit to what we can get
done in the next four years first the
American people understand we cannot
continue to have a pathological liar as
president with tomorrow's big prize 125
delegates now at stake Bernie Sanders
makes his case to America
[Music]
winglets says phone-banking in Seattle
right now for Bernie
[Applause]
Michigan Dearborn Fieldhouse in Dearborn
Michigan I'm Martha McCallum and I'm
Brett there we are just hours away from
voting in what some people are calling
Super Tuesday 2.0 six states will decide
on their choices for which Democrat
should go up against President Trump
this fall 352 delegates at stake the
fallout from last week's Super Tuesday
voting has left us with a two-man race
former Vice President Joe Biden riding
the wave of an incredible comeback true
by the surging in two polls here today
in Michigan against the former
frontrunner Vermont senator Bernie
Sanders the self-described Democratic
Socialist who is feared by many in the
second time you spent tonight we get a
second opportunities and welcomes actors
say there is about what he believes and
what direction he wants to take his
party and the nation ladies and
gentlemen please welcome senator Bernie
Sanders
[Applause]
using the elbow block pioneered by bill
mention that obviously there's the
coronavirus situation going on and
president Trump is about to speak from
the White House about the task force and
you are able to see that streaming right
now on Fox Business and on its streaming
I should say on Fox news.com and on Fox
Business so with that in mind let's
start and dive in here with our first
question this evening welcome again
senator Sanders which comes from octi
who is a supporter of yours Marty good
evening senator Sanders the coronavirus
has quickly become a public health
threat with a global reach and infection
and death rates are rising here in the
United States what is your assessment of
the Trump administration's handling of
the outbreak and what would you do
differently
good you don't mind if I stand you had
your choice um sadly we have an
administration in Washington that has
shown the world that it does not believe
in science its attitude toward climate
change which it thinks as a hoax is
telling the whole world how do we trust
this administration dealing with an
international crisis healthcare crisis
of the coronavirus when you appoint vice
president pence an individual also
doesn't much believe in science but
you're telling the whole world is that
we're politicizing this issue rather
than dealing with it from a data
research scientific basis so first of
all this is what I would do you need
scientists leading the effort not
politicians this cannot be in any way
shape or form perceived to be a
political issue number two we will talk
I'm sure about Medicare for all but when
I talk about health care being a human
right and all people having health care
the coronavirus crisis makes that
abundantly clear as to why it should be
you've got millions of people in this
country today who may feel that they
have a symptom but you know what they
cannot afford to go to a doctor and
they're gonna go to work we have a
president the United States you know
doesn't matter go to work we have a
president as absurd things so what we
need to do is right now make it clear
that all
Americans if you are feeling sick go to
a doctor it will be paid for right
hesitate to go to the doctor as all of
you know or should know we are the only
major country on Earth that does not
have paid family and medical leave so
what does that mean in practical terms
when half of the people in this country
are living paycheck to paycheck today
you're feeling sick
maybe you're coughing maybe you have a
fever but you know what you got to get
to work even got to go to your job in
McDonald's or Burger King or Walmart
because you don't go to work you don't
get a paycheck you don't get a paycheck
you don't feed your family what happens
if you have that virus then you're going
to work just spreading it to other
people so right now while we move to
make paid family and medical leave
national policy at this moment at least
we say to every worker if you are sick
stay home
and we will figure out a way to make
sure that you are compensated and get
your salary so your family doesn't
suffice senator Sanders you know to
Monty's path now let's for the question
turn on you know standing around the
president right now are a lot of
scientists dr. Tony Fauci yo and the
head of the CDC a lot of experts do not
have those exports they work well what
would you do differently to his well but
here is the point I would not be a
president saying to the world oh by the
way what was he going to [ __ ] saying
this right I have a natural ability to
understand the problem is that true or
not but I think he did say that yeah
you dope you said that to all reporters
at the CDC but my point is first thought
is a president I don't claim if I'm
president and I'm the world's greatest
scientific expert on climate change of
coronavirus you listen to the scientist
you don't say stupid things you don't
suggest the people that you can go to
work that's not with the side guys let's
talk about the economy the markets the
markets drop 2,000 points today based on
the virus Airlines cruise lines
hospitality industry obviously taking a
big hit what if those companies needed a
bailout to stay afloat and avoid losing
thousands of jobs well ask compress you
right how would you handle requests by
American companies but for a bailout one
of the differences if I might say
between Joe Biden and myself is that Joe
bailed out the crooks on Wall Street we
nearly destroyed our economy not five
years ago I'm using the word crooks
you're not right that's true okay okay
and these guys after destroying the
economy they came to Congress and they
hate you know they've opposed they want
to cut Social Security Medicare and
Medicaid many of these Wall Street
executives but they came to Congress
listen bail us out and what I said at
that point is I understand the economy
is in trouble and if you want to bail
out at a time of massive income and
wealth inequality that's fine
go to your billionaire friends and we'll
put a special tax on billionaires the
economy and it wasn't only the top
funding it turned out to be trillions of
dollars in zero interest loans so my
answer right now is we will take a look
at the economy obviously we don't want
the economy to tanked but when three
people in America Brett and Martha own
more wealth than the bottom half of this
country when 49 percent of all new
income goes to the top one percent but
we have more income and wealth
inequality at any time in the
hundred years if we need to bail out the
economy you know who does it the people
on top not working-class people who are
struggling today number two when we
talked about bailing out the economy
this is not going to just be more tax
breaks and subsidies for large
corporations we'll talk about building
up the economy let's provide health care
to all Americans as a human right how's
that let's talk about raising the
minimum wage to a living wage of $15 and
also you talked about building it out if
it's simply helping the people on top
with taxpayer money from the
middle-class no way choo choo questions
that are part of one the first one is
you've talked about raising taxes on
corporations raising taxes on Americans
to some extent as well would you if you
were in the Oval Office today given
what's going on in the economy right now
concerns that perhaps there might be a
recession coming as some people suspect
could happen as a result of all this
would you hold off on raising taxes
while that situation is going on well
what I would do no I think raising taxes
does two things number one it is one
means of dealing with a rural test level
of income and wealth inequality all
right I don't believe you know Mike
Bloomberg you know as you know what I
have here notice that they the question
is premised on the idea that raising
taxes is bad for the economy Bernie
should be dis undoing that notion I
think one thing you do with with
progressive taxation is you say to the
wealthiest people in this country whose
wealth is exploding while we have a half
a million people sleeping out on the
streets including 30,000 veterans where
we have kids who cannot afford to go to
college yeah we're gonna ask the
wealthiest people in the country to pay
you're answering that question I think
the same way that you would have
answered it a month ago before the virus
happened but I'm asking you in the
middle of right now when we are
potentially in an economic crisis you
doesn't get companies that are halting
conferences and cruise ships and all
these things would you say yeah but you
know what I still believe that in this
moment we need to realize I will not
become president until January and the
economic situation will be different
today in this moment if our today
what I would their well again I would
raise taxes on billionaires for dealing
with the issue of income and wealth
inequality and you need education
environmental protection and
homelessness but in terms of an economic
stimulus which i think is what you're
talking about we have an infrastructure
today which is crumbling right before
our eyes we have millions of people
spending half of their income I mean the
other thing he should be saying is if I
had been president since January 2017
the situation would be different today
in good-paying jobs our rebuilding our
crumbling infrastructure roads bridges I
don't have to tell the people of
Michigan who have lived through Flint
Michigan about a horrible water system
testkit that he's gonna give out all
over that area other billionaires who
are at pharmaceutical companies are
putting you know the pedal to the metal
to try to find treatments and vaccines
so there are good things that
billionaires do in a time of crisis
right Martha would take a step back I
understand that and I'm not here to
demonize anybody I really am NOT I have
nothing personal against Bill Gates was
done many good things in his life his
foundation has done good things but
don't you think it's a bit absurd that
in the wealthiest country in the history
of the world we have to depend upon the
generosity of billionaires to help us
[Applause]
then move on to the next audience
question but if you had to if you had to
would you close down the borders no I
mean what you don't want to do right now
we have a president who has a propagated
xenophobic anti-immigrant sentiment from
before he was elected what we need to do
is have the scientists take a hard look
at what we need to do there are
communities where the virus is spreading
what does that mean it may mean self
quarantine it may be not having public
assemblies but let's not go back to the
same old thing isn't it interesting that
a president who has been demagoguing and
demonizing immigrants the first thing
that he could think about is closing
down of the border so we need scientists
to tell us the appropriate approach not
a political okay let's turn to an
audience question
Alison very solid so far too liberal it
seems like you have the right ideas but
most moderate Democrats it seems like
Joe Biden could get more accomplished in
office so how will you ensure that you
can accomplish all of your goals in
office and leave the country in a better
place after four years
thanks Alison um I reject the idea I
really do
that's one of the things that bothers me
you know I hear it every day I hear done
media I hear from my opponents Bernie is
an extremist Bernie is too radical okay
let's deal with it
it's raising a starvation minimum wage
so he's gonna do these things aren't
radical but the question about getting
things done is a relevant one and I hope
he answers it so $15 an hour
a living wage a radical idea is making
public colleges and universities
tuition-free so that all of our people
have the opportunity to get a higher
education in a competitive global
economy is that a radical idea it's
doing what every other major country on
earth does guaranteeing health care to
all as a right I live 50 miles away from
the Canadian border
this is not a communist society up there
Montreal they guarantee healthcare to
all they spend 50% of what we spend love
Montreal he's passing a medicare-for-all
single-payer system a radical idea and
last point Donald Trump and I was on the
network a whole lot Donald you're
probably watching how are you taking a
press conference right now water to say
hello to the president he's actually
having a news conference always in the
Bob sure he's watching Fox of the side
there you know he's kind of addicted to
your station Trump thinks that climate
change is a hoax and that's because he
doesn't understand or respect science I
believe that sigh that climate change is
an existential threat to this planet I
will listen to the scientists who tell
us that we have got to move aggressively
to transform our energy system away from
fossil fuel to energy efficiency and
sustainable energy and through a green
new deal by the way we can create up to
20 million good-paying jobs so my point
is I reject
I appreciate Allison raising the
question I just don't think any of just
back to Allison's question which was you
know how you would get things done in
Congress when there are a lot of folks
who don't agree with all the ideas that
you just mentioned and here is one of
them this is Hillary Clinton she talked
about you in a documentary that was
released earlier this week watch this
Murray just drove me crazy he was in
Congress for years years he had one
senator support him nobody likes him
nobody wants to work with him he got
nothing done he was a career politician
he had he did not work till he was like
41 and then he got elected to something
it was all just baloney and I feel so
bad that you know people got sucked into
it Wow that's unlike Secretary Clinton I
don't want to relive 2016 where 2000
[Applause]
what what I would say on a good day my
wife likes me but also if you guys
looked at some of the polling that they
do for United States senators you know
they do polls how popular you are in
most cases I turn out to be the most
popular United States senator senator
President Trump continues to tweet he
continues to tweet even today that the
Democratic primary race is rigged
against you he said the same thing in
2016 this was only can you agree with
President Trump well you know given the
collapse of the stock market today given
the spread of the coronavirus one might
think to tell you the truth that a
President of the United States would be
worrying about some other things rather
than the Democratic primary but maybe
I'm wrong on it look Trump has his
agenda and I have the feeling that deep
in his heart he's really not all that
worried about me I appreciate his
concerns I you will forgive me if I
don't necessarily trust him or believe
him but I will say this right he has
some very smart political consultants
around them and a couple of weeks ago
political consultants um buddy asked him
why would you rather run against Sanders
or Trump or whatever and what the guy
said I forgot his name he said you know
what running against a movement makes me
nervous because they understand that our
campaign is more than just a campaign we
are creating a multiracial multinational
guys I know a lot of people in my
audience pop Bernie just say yes it's
rigged against me that's the stuff that
has caused problems for him when he says
we're against the Republican and
Democratic establishment that means a
lot of Democrats don't vote for him and
they didn't on Super Tuesday I don't
think this is stupid
[Music]
I believe in he has a next question
Jonathan there is where something is
okay senator Sanders if you are met with
an obstructionist Congress what
compromise would you be willing to make
to still promote your chief policies I
didn't hit less one of the question what
compromises would you be willing to make
to some promote your chief policies only
in other words if you have a Congress
that doesn't agree with you what
compromises what you made to get it
across the finish line
look I should tell you I know that
there's another mythology going out
around me that everybody hates me we
heard that from them Secretary Clinton
that I can't work for it with anybody
check the record and you'll find that in
the 1990s when I was in the house I
passed more roll call amendments on the
floor of the House bipartisan than any
other member of the House year after
year idea so in other words when we see
people who have come an interest I don't
care what party they're in for example
there were and have been a taught today
a number of Republicans who are outraged
that we are spending ten times more for
prescription drugs same prescription
drugs than people in other countries
double getting ripped off day and night
by the collusion and price-fixing in the
pharmaceutical industry there are
Republicans who want to address that I
will work with them on that issue there
are Republicans who know that our
infrastructure roads bridges water
systems are collapsing I will certainly
work with them on that I worked with
Mike Lee you know Mike Lee of Utah Mike
and I was a very conservative Republican
from Utah Mike and I worked together to
pass for the first time under the War
Powers Act a Senate resolution getting
the United States out of the horrific
war in Yemen all right Mike Lee a
conservative Republican I worked
together enough I work with the late
John McCain who was a friend of mine we
had different points of view but I
respected John immensely John and I
worked together when I was chairman in
US Senate Committee on Veterans Affairs
I'm perhaps the most comprehensive
veterans bill passed in modern history
so the idea that I cannot work with
Republicans on issues where we can come
together it's just not accurate right so
a lot of the questions that deal
with trying to pin you down on specifics
all right go for it hello you're going
to pay for your program now several
economists have really tried to
calculate the cost of the total list I'm
talking medicare-for-all green New Deal
free college housing all three college
public colleges on the university
understand the Kelvin will not be free
online estimates put it at a staggering
55 trillion look at this theory over the
next no that's the propaganda it's hard
to a lot of money all right so just give
me a second there's one second 1 million
seconds is 12 days ago 1 trillion
seconds is 30 1689 years ago that's one
trillion you're talking 55 trillion
dollars hold on if entirely covered by a
protractor it would be nearly double the
existing level of taxes if entirely
covered by borrowing it would soar the
national debt to 78 trillion dollars now
the national debt is 23 trillion dollars
right now and Counting so how can you
pay for all this good all right
no I don't have the teleprompter barri
but I'll do my best
all right how much to get the numbers
right ok ok good question all right
let's deal with it fair question Bernie
you're proposing bold ideas how you
gonna pay for right with a big price tag
yes
all right let's deal with them Medicare
for all how you gonna pay for Medicare
for all fair question how are we paying
for it right now
we're paying for it right now by
spending twice as much per person as the
people of any other country the average
family in America makes approximately
$60,000 eeeh they are paying $12,000 you
a 20% of the income for health care
their employer is paying even more so
what I propose is instead of you an
average worker paying $12,000 a year
what we are gonna do is eliminate all
Prima's and now let's be fair about this
sometimes we're not fair on television
all right
premiums are gone got it no one's paying
any more premiums no one's paying any
more co-payments on the Medicare for all
the absurd concept of a deductible is
gone all right
we have done the lower because we're
going to end the greed and collusion of
the pharmaceutical industry nobody under
my plan pays more than $200 a year
for prescription drugs okay all of that
not that no one's paying that then I say
to you look health care is not free I'm
not suggesting to you it's your the
average worker you're making 60,000 a
year what I say to you there are various
options out there that we put on our
website number one we have proposed a 4%
income tax on you exempting the first
twenty nine thousand dollars so people
make them twenty five nine or thousand
or less don't pay anything that would
mean to you would pay four percent of
thirty-one thousand dollars that's
twelve hundred dollars a year you know
what guys
comprehensive health care undermine
Medicare for all plan by the way that
glutes dental care hearing aids
eyeglasses and home health care
twelve hundred bucks a year is a pretty
good deal it seems to me that doesn't
cover at all that does not cover it all
what we impose is a seven and a half
percent payroll tax on employers that
will save employers money and then
through progressive taxation we fund the
rest okay here we go
give me a minute that's all right you
took a minute give me a minute okay
right now the estimate is from the
Department of Health and Human Services
that over the next ten years this
country will be spending about fifty
trillion dollars got a five trillion a
year okay according to recent studies
Medicare for all will save money because
we are doing away with the profiteering
of the insurance companies and the drug
companies and we're here's the main
point right now we have to as a nation
admit it's the thousands of private
insurance plans which cost a fortune to
do do away with that because you have
one broad plan you could say some five
four or five hundred billion dollars so
to answer your question right now the
federal government through Medicaid
Medicare and other public health
programs we're spending about 30 billion
a year we think you'll need about 47
billion to fund what I want to fund
that's 17 billion dollars more and it
comes through the mechanisms that I
talked about this is just
yeah I hope some people understand that
these numbers these numbers are not
inspiring that much confidence in me I
think it's gonna cost more I got it
we have documented how we do pay for
that let me go to free tuition in public
colleges and universities and canceling
all student debt how do we pay for that
we pay for it through a lotta stacks on
Wall Street speculation will also see
their taxes go up you also talked about
cutting defense spending when you look
at defense spending we spent six point
four trillion dollars over 19 years in
Iraq and Afghanistan if you said I'm not
gonna spend one dollar after that you
wouldn't even come close to making the
money back if you cut defense spending
to cover the plan that you're talking
about it fifty five trillion dollars all
right one second or we talk let me if
you look at he's now muddling
issue-by-issue I told you how we had fun
Medicare fraud you're saying and this is
where we need from media kind of honesty
and respect in the in this sense no no
I'm not reading up no I'm not well
here's numbers then if right now you're
the average worker okay you paying
$12,000 you have to health care and if I
said to that work on that I can provide
better health care for substantially
less but you'll have to pay more in
taxes I admitted okay so let's say you
paid twelve hundred two thousand dollars
more in taxes for comprehensive health
care but you're not paying twelve
thousand dollars in premiums co-payments
and out-of-pocket expenses who has the
better deal well that may be true for
the twelve thousand dollar-a-year person
for the thirty or forty or thousand
dollar a year per person who likes the
health plan they have from their from
their employer that's all there's no
100 million Americans who have coverage
that they like but you're gonna take
that away from them no we're gonna no
first of all that's 150 million and this
is what we're doing every year do you
know many people lose their health
insurance every year because they lose
their job when they transfer whatever
may happen
they quit about 50 million people he'll
lose their health insurance doctor okay
what we are doing is what every other
country on earth does why do you think
why do you think it's a great I'm
pointing I don't need to be I don't need
to be argument about really I'm looking
at you you know I don't know but it
could be many of my Democratic opponents
the same thing all right why do you
think that it's a wonderful idea that
employers in this country are burdened
with the cost of health care why is it
would probably agree with you they'd
probably not want to have that burden
which one has covered a lot of people
what you're getting working for you
right you want to provide health care it
is enormous
so every other country has said you
don't want you're a small businessman do
your damn business don't worry about
health care we will cover all health
care for you as a human right so I think
I just want to end on this note and the
coronavirus makes this point we lose and
we lose conservatively guys about 30,000
people every year that's conservative
who died because they don't get to a
doctor when they should that's a tragedy
but you can see the absurdity of the
current system today when people cannot
afford to go to the doctor who may be
struggling with the coronavirus I don't
know how you can do anybody can defend
the system where we're spending twice as
much per person and yet you've got 87
million uninsured or underinsured it is
an indefensible system unless we worry
about the health care industry which
made a hundred billion in profits
licensed under we gave you the time and
we want
[Music]
all right very good so we've got a lot
going on here Bernie I mean he's really
doing well generally speaking there
always is still going making sure that
there's a lot going on here and Bernie
is doing the best he can he is getting
tough questions there is follow-up this
has always been a point of contention
which is people like to distort the
front the money stuff with with the
programs but there are also still open
questions and that's me telling it to
you with peace and love let me say
thanks to heroes shadow who cheered a
thousand bits on Twitch I appreciate
that
a welcome if you're just joining us
we've been having discussions and
answering questions about what we are
seeing here I do want to say thanks to
some new David Pakman show members
really really great people who have
signed up Ben X ler is new member number
five tonight at join pakman.com Jonathan
Sanborn is new member number six
Kyle Hanna is new member number seven
this evening Andrew Dewar is new member
number eight tonight
Colton Hahn is new member number nine
and jonatha way I already mentioned
Jonathan yes that's not okay yeah I
don't want to mention Jonathan twice I
would love to but only your membership
only counts once Jonathan join us at
join pakman.com it's cheap we've got a
really great discount code 20/20 now
that saves you a whole bunch of money
let me answer some of the super chats
that came in kwb asked how many hours do
you work on the show per week I don't
know the answer to that many it's my
full-time job Captain Obvious has not
sold on the economic argument David even
under a recession I think Trump would
still be at 43 no evidence for a dip so
far yes this is not about approval this
is about who chooses to go out and vote
based on their perception of the economy
it is very difficult to unseat an
incumbent when the economy is perceived
as good Republican Democrat doesn't
matter
quirky quips says are you feeling okay I
hear a possible throat issue I
go running about an hour ago and yeah
I'm feeling a little bit I don't know
I've got a little I don't think it's
asthmatic so to speak but I've got a
little something going on since I since
I went running Shana's says really wish
primary's moved to ranked voting with
early ballots friends here in Arizona
have already lost their votes due to
dropouts I'm against early voting in
primaries on that basis although I
understand the importance and raising
turnout it's a complicated issue
Adam ranked choice would potentially
solve it if you vote if your first
choice is out on election day your vote
is transferred single transferable vote
would also work Adam Waddington says
should Bernie directly address Biden's
mental decline in the debate wouldn't
help us Cal hey wouldn't it help his
case moving forward I think it's risky
for Bernie to do that because then Biden
could bring up you're almost 80 and just
had a heart attack and that's not a
problem Biden has I think it would start
to get into an argument about mental
health versus physical health think it's
dangerous I doubt he will do it I would
be shocked if Bernie did it do you think
Fox may save Bernie's campaign by
bringing up Biden's cognitive decline
explicitly lol standing up was some
clever shade Bernie always does that he
did that at the last town hall he always
asked to stand up I don't think it would
really move the needle very much
unfortunately for Bernie big election
tomorrow we have another question from
the audience and this is nina nina with
a question some of joe biden's answers
don't make sense do you think it's
acceptable for a presidential candidate
to respond to questions like Joe Biden
does oh boy teeing it up well let me
just let's see what he says this is
perfect I look you just say this you
know Joe Biden is a friend of mine I've
known him for him many many years when
we do our events and our allied rallies
we try to give we respect people in a
sense and we give really substantive
these guys will take maybe two
long-winded answers but we take people
there are real crises facing this
country when I give a speech often it's
45 min
or an hour let's see what he does
because there are a lot of challenges of
the country faces and I got to talk
about him you know I think Joe was
somewhere and we was the owner of
Michigan or someplace else the other day
and he spoke for seven minutes I don't
know how you say anything other than you
know minimal discussion in seven minutes
so all that I have always believed is
that if we leave in democracy no
candidate has got to be honest with the
people about what he or she believes
given the many many challenges facing
our country and when you do that when
you're honest and you look at the hard
issues so you're gonna take on the
fossil fuel industry Bernie Tiede hair
cream or the drug companies it brings
forth opposition I know that I get
beaten up every day that's fine that's
what I do
but all I would say is not to criticize
Joe but to say that I think the American
people in this incredibly complicated
and difficult moment in our history are
entitled to thoughtful answers to the
crises we face this isn't a personal
attack but he gets to Nina's question
and the question of Joe Biden's mental
acuity is not something that just comes
up anywhere Democrats have brought this
up including senator Cory Booker who
endorsed Joe Biden today tickle is you
just said that two minutes ago Thank You
forgeting what you said
just two minutes ago I think that Castro
has some really legitimate concerns
about can he be someone in a long
grueling campaign that can get the ball
over the line and either say something
there are definitely moments where you
listen to Joe Biden and you this is not
going to help tomorrow he's having
trouble completing thoughts sender your
thoughts I'm not gonna go at that level
in attacking Joe Joe and I have Bernie's
might not see what people to decide that
all I can say is Joe and I have very
significant political differences and
I'm not gonna make making you know
personal attacks on Joe that's not what
I do but Joe and I but threaten Martha I
think it's you know we have you know Joe
has been in the Senate and I've been in
the Senate in the house for a long time
Joe voted for the war in Iraq I led the
opposition against the woods y'all voted
for the Wall Street bailout I voted
against the Joe has been on the floor of
the house over the years talking about
the need to cut Social Security veterans
programs or the veteran other programs I
have led the opposition to those cuts
Joe's views on women's issues Joe has
supported the Hyde Amendment which would
deny low-income women to use Medicaid
funds for their own reproductive needs I
strongly disagree with that approach
also on issue after issue even in terms
of how we raise funds for our campaign
Joe has the support of 60 at least 16
billionaires funding his campaign let me
just ask you one question you said a
moment ago that he gives seven-minute
answers you're suggesting that he lacks
substance no I did well I'm just saying
look I'm here we're talking about real
issues hey all right
we can go on for three hours they're
trying to goad Bernie to attack Biden's
cognition Bernie smart not to do it it
won't get him a single additional
delegate guys I can't do it in seven
minutes like you know there are too many
issues this healthcare education climate
change immigration reform criminal
justice roof line how you do that in
seven minutes
so all that I'm saying Malcolm is that I
think it's a candidate for president
your respect to the people and you have
to have the courage or the desire to say
hey this is what
where I'm coming from this is my view
you disagree with me fine but I can't do
that in seven minutes of the speech
[Applause]
someone from Russia a country that was
greatly impacted by the negative effects
of socialism what assurances can you
offer myself and other people impacted
by socialism democratic socialism will
not have the same result I think that's
a better question welcome welcome
Martin what happened and existed in the
Soviet Union was not socialism and
communism whether in Cuba whether in the
Soviet Union whether in other countries
was mocked by totalitarianism was mocked
by throwing millions of people into the
gulag Stalinism was about as bad as it
is it gone but right near you're from
Russia I don't know if you've ever
visited Finland as Finland Finland is a
neighbor to Russia they have a very
democratic society with strong
democratic socialist principles
everybody in Finland has health care as
a right their educational system is
perhaps the best in the world and
college there is free
they take environmental responsibility
of very very seriously they have one of
the lowest rates of childhood poverty in
the industrialized world and you know
what their voting rate people who
participate in their elections is a lot
higher than it is in the United States
so when we talk about democratic
socialism Margaret I'm talking about
Finland I'm talking about Denmark I'm
talking about there's always a lot of
confusion three years of the world who
have used their government to try to
improve life for working families not
just the people on top
basically since the 90s if you look at
examples in Sweden and Denmark they have
been lowering or cutting property taxes
lowering corporate taxes allowing
vouchers for schools for public schools
and private schools which is one of the
reasons why their education has improved
the founder of IKEA who famously came
back came back left his home country
moved here has now gone back because he
says the tax environment for him is
getting better so they appear to be
moving away more towards market reform
and not towards what you're describing
you'd like to see here all right but if
you and I'm not an expert on the current
economy in Sweden but disagree with me
if you want the Sweden guarantee
healthcare to all people is a human
right
yeah but they're finding other ways to
pay for it because they have to improve
their economy but they guarantee every
person regardless of income yes go to
college is that the case of the United
States that certainly not six point five
five point six million people I think in
Denmark of course of course but well my
point is is what these country people
demand we have in America unbelievably
the highest rate of childhood poverty of
almost any major country on earth in
terms of the african-american community
like one-third of our kids
african-american kids are in poverty
check out the poverty rate for kids in
Scandinavia it'll be far far lower their
retirement benefits for their older
people are better their wages that their
workers make are better so I cannot give
you I should know it I don't all of the
details about the tax system in Sweden
but all I can say is they have gone a
long way to eliminate poverty to make
sure that all of their people have the
basic needs that they need in order to
live good lives and by the way in
international study at the International
study it turns out that countries like
Denmark are the happiest countries on
earth and you know why because if you
don't have to worry about how you're
gonna pay for health care if you don't
have to worry about how you're gonna
afford to send your kids to college if
you're not to worry about the cost of
child care if you're earning a decent
wage even if you're paying more in taxes
that you may be paying in the United
States that takes a huge load of stress
or you your backs
[Applause]
cuba and authoritarian regimes there are
a few moments in races that seem like
turning points and many experts looked
at that moment on 60 minutes when you
talked about Fidel Castro's literary
literacy program as a turning point in
this race do you agree at all I thought
no look I have spent my entire life
fighting for working people and fighting
for democracy and and Brett if you check
my record I have condemned
authoritarianism whether it is in the
Soviet Union whether it's in Cuba
whether it is in Saudi Arabia they're
not having too many too many free
elections they're Emirates wherever it
may be i happen to be old-fashioned and
i believe in democracy so if you look at
a country like china for example today
is trying to a democracy of course it's
not a democracy
it is an authoritarian country and she
is taking it in a bad direction but what
can we say about china in the last 50
years with anybody in their right mind
deny that extreme poverty in china has
been reduced can anyone deny that of
course not
does that mean we approve of the Chinese
government no it does it but I think you
know sometimes that I know it's hard
given you know got you're quite not you
know and you're given the media that we
do everything everything else you say
something and people could beat up on
you I think you got to tell the truth so
if in China they've reduced extreme
poverty does that make me a communist
who supports China no I'm just telling
you a simple fact I guess it was
Democrats who were also good now
Stephanie Miller a Democrat from Florida
said Castro was a murderous dictator who
oppressed his own people his literacy
program wasn't altruistic it was a
cynical effort to spread his dangerous
philosophy and consolidate well that's a
Democrat well so what we've got a lot of
Democrats who attacking me as well you
know that um nothing new there uh but
you know if you remember what Barack
Obama said when when Obama correctly try
to bring the normalized relationship
with you but what he said I don't want
to misquote him but he said something a
power phrasing to the effect that
kuipers made progress in health care and
education Hueber you know yeah so that
doesn't mean you support
authoritarian governments hopeful so the
New York Times just wrote a very large
piece on the how the Soviets they I
don't have to only worry about [ __ ] so I
gotta worry about the New York Times to
about the Kremlin in the 80s and
suggesting that they used you there's a
picture from the piece for propaganda
purposes here's a quote from the piece
the documents show the Soviets intensive
preparation to use mr. Sanders interest
in their country to their advantage what
do you say about that I say that the New
York Times got it very very wrong what I
established in nineteen eighties is
Mayor of the City of Burlington he
assists the city program with Yaroslava
in the Soviet Union you know who was
advocating in a very strong way the
establishment assists the city programs
all over America a communist named
Ronald Reagan by the way by the way
that's it's the city program today is
still in existence thirty five years
later it means that doctors for much
sort of coming over to the United States
I think the hockey team came over they
have been student exchanges so let me be
very clear I think that was a great idea
I want to see more rather than spending
money billions of dollars on the
military I want kids from all over the
world to visit the United and show how
they did it show what they did at that
point I think The Times article makes
that point on paragraph 203 there were I
think dozens assist the city programs
with with the Soviet era we so many more
questions from the audience
what about colleges and paying for
college so that is a real question from
somebody in our audience as our Town
Hall continues with Senator Bernie
Sanders
[Music]
and going to a break there if you're
just joining us and you're watching on
YouTube we have been bringing you all
sorts of stuff from the last six months
of primary coverage election results
Town Hall's debates etc please do like
and subscribe like and subscribe like
and subscribe on YouTube it costs
nothing it really helps us it really
doesn't our streams have been doing
better and better the more that we've
been making sure people know to LIKE and
subscribe
when watching on YouTube if you're
watching on Twitch make sure to hit that
follow button as well none of these
things cost the damn penny my friends
let me say thank you to a few other
folks who have signed up on my website a
join pakman.com is the place to do it we
have a very modest goal of 25 new
members come 'no mammoth is new member
number 10 tonight kenneth Johansson is
new member number 11 and William gaucho
is new member number 12 this evening
really appreciate your support
grab a membership at join pakman.com
it's quick it's cheap you get great
extras and you're directly supporting
our channel which I so so so appreciate
over on Twitch I want to say thanks to
niandra 33 who has grabbed the twitch
prime sub the Welsh elects who has
subscribed with prime bolo has
subscribed and says Pakman Pakman Pakman
and rebel without a cause is now a
subscriber for seven months so is inna
racoon and big bro beans as well as
Parker Moss and yeah I think I'm caught
up there a few super chats max asks will
Bernie talk about Biden's cognitive
capacity no he was already goaded into
it by the hosts and he didn't take the
bait I think it was smart Bernie's not
gonna win Michigan tomorrow because he
says Biden's losing it he's just not
gonna do it I think it's good strategy
for Bernie not to do it first in last
Kappa says should Bernie play up the
crowds vibes and turn to them for more
answers to tough questions it was
effective when he did it a thanks I for
the YouTube subscription mcfreak says it
seems like people don't understand you
need socialism to rein in the excess of
capital as
from becoming too greedy and turning
into a fascist state you need a mixed
economy to have a democracy I think
you're maybe that's not the way I would
put it
Dylan Hart says Joe's going to be the
establishment government's brainless
meat puppy gurps says tax to GDP ratio
in the u.s. is 24 ye u is 34 in Nordic
countries its 40s a difference of
trillions plenty of money in the economy
to pay Bernie's plan in the long run
Bernie should have just said that Dan
Hertz says I'm 12 miles away I'm going
to go check it out I don't know what
you're referring to
Isaiah Gilyard says somewhere in this
debate Bernie needs to challenge the
media to vet Biden in the way they do to
him we may see that I would be surprised
Jeremy comfort says Sanders will bring
us to egalitarianism first in last kappa
asks is your throat tickle just a
distraction I believe that it is I
believe that it is I do have a tickle in
my throat
let's get back to the townhall here with
Bernie Sanders on Fox News which is from
Sharif hello
even in Sarah Sanders sniffing as a
palestinian-american I and many like
myself would like to know what your plan
is to bring a fair resolution to the
palestinian-israeli conflict
[Applause]
nobody's gonna like this well you know
Sharif this has been an issue that we
struggle with for many many decades Oh
needs a drink of water but this is what
I will tell you and I tell you this is a
jewish-american
somebody who was a kid lived on a
kibbutz in Israel the United States
cannot continue to maintain a one-sided
policy toward the Middle East what we
need
Israel needs absolutely to be guaranteed
the right to live in peace and security
no question about that and I will defend
that right but the Palestinian people
need also to understand that the United
States believes they have a right to
live in dignity and with justice and
what I am very concerned about what I am
very concerned about is that over many
years especially under Netanyahu we have
seen a right-wing drift in Israel
I have called Netanyahu a racist I
believe that is true on the other hand
would you look at Gaza you are looking
at a terrible terrible situation where
youth unemployment is I believe
somewhere around 60 or 70 percent people
are unable to leave serious health
conditions that is unsustainable so what
the United States has got to do and I'm
not here to tell you it is easy but to
treat both sides with respect we are
putting a lot of money into Israel and
to say you know what you just can't use
that money on weapons we want you to sit
down with the Palestinians I know it's
hard let's work out a two-state solution
let's end the encroachment of the
settlements on Palestinian land and
dimension there's a lot of people's is
likely and up until this and continue to
have just a pro-israel policy all right
next question
[Applause]
there you go hi senator Sanders as a
first-year college student here at the
University of Michigan Dearborn
I understand attending University can be
expensive but at the same time I
understand that I'm making an investment
in my future what would you say to
families who have worked hard to save up
money so their children can go to
college with minimal debt or to
graduates that have worked hard after
graduating to pay off their student
loans what would you consider these
people in your plan to cancel all
student loan debt for public
universities well I certainly would
consider those people in all
middle-class and working families in my
plans as we bring change to America but
in terms of college let me rephrase your
question and tell me where you disagree
with me a hundred plus years ago in a
fairly radical action working-class
people said you know what we want our
kids not to be working in factories or
on farms or in the fields we want them
to have an education okay and what they
said which 100 plus years ago is pretty
radical idea they said you know what
everybody should have a right to go to
public schools roughly from first grade
through 12th grade and that was
transformative in America lie went to a
public school most of my kids in my
public school we didn't have any money
we had a pretty damn good education okay
the world has changed from where it was
30 years ago or 50 years ago technology
the global economy has changed it I
don't think it's a radical idea to say
that when we talk about public education
it shouldn't just be from 1st grade to
12th grade right should be through
college or trade school as well that's
why I believe
that's why I believe we should make
public colleges and universities
tuition-free ants why I also believe
that through a modest tax on Wall Street
speculation we should cancel all student
debt in this country all right so I
think I think the question that those
families that you mentioned should be
asking is what would he do with that
might be right there Trump and his
friends gave two years ago a trillion
dollars in tax breaks to the 1% and
large corporations how could that be
right
how could it be right that the fossil
fuel industry which is today with their
product if you like destroying our
planet gets tens of billions of dollars
a year in subsidies and tax breaks how
could it be right that the taxpayers
this country bailed out the crooks on
Wall Street so I have no apology for
saying and by the way it is happening in
America state after state community if
the community understands the truth of
what I'm saying they are making public
colleges and universities tuition-free
and that is exactly what has got to
happen all right so there's some
speculation about who Joe Biden would
pick if he were to get the nomination
and some of the people that are said to
be on that list maybe Cory Booker Kamala
Harris Amy Klobuchar who would be on
your list
you looking for a job to be very
bipartisan I don't I think it's a little
bit premature I haven't won the
nomination yet but I think my gut
feeling is that it must be a woman I
would look to women first but they would
be women by the way who hold my
political views so one of those is
Elizabeth Warren you said it would be
nice to have Elizabeth Warren support
have you asked for it
have I asked for it Elizabeth and I
talked we have talked for 20 years we
talk on a regular basis
interesting we talk on a regular basis
alright what's your next question that's
really lightning okay so maybe it's the
same answer to this question this
question is who's your closest friend in
Washington my wife I have you know
developed over the years a lot of good
friends in the house good friends in the
Senate and by the way not all the know
my Democrats and one of the things that
you know I have seen is there a lot of
decent people who are Republicans we
disagree that does not mean to say that
good that they're not good people and
not honest people if you don't get the
nomination will you feel any
responsibility for taking a job away
from Larry David you know I saw it David
he was moaning and groaning and I say
hey look I'm gonna give you a good job
for the next four years you're gonna
make a fortune what are you complaining
about doctor senator Sanders we
appreciate your time thank you very very
excited thanks very much
[Music]
I'll show listen no missteps by Bernie
Sanders he did they you know they
brought up socialism a bunch of times
the socialism question may even have
been planted to be perfectly honest and
we're investigating that right now but
no missteps I just don't believe it will
really make a difference tomorrow
that's my instinct if this did really
well it got what an audience like if it
did incredibly well four million people
saw this in total many of them are just
Fox News viewers who are voting in the
Democratic primary the Democrats you
know aren't realistically gonna be
voting in tomorrow's the these few
states but Bernie did well Bernie didn't
fall for going after Joe Biden on
cognitive decline it would have been
fruitless
absolutely and complete completely
fruitless so I think that he did I think
I think that he did quite well I just
don't know how much of a difference it's
going to make before you leave please
hit like and subscribe on YouTube I know
many of you are gonna head out now that
the Town Hall is over please do me that
favor with peace and love hit subscribe
and like because it really does help our
streams and it'll help tomorrow we'll be
back for hours tomorrow night with the
results and I I appreciate everybody who
has been doing that let me say thanks to
Lisa Patenaude who is today's 13th new
member of the day hero shadow is
tonight's 14th new member I very much
appreciate your support we do have this
tremendous tremendous coupon code up
there 20 20 now saves you 66 percent
which is absolutely insane absolutely
insane I also want to say thanks to
chill SD chill SD has subscribed for
three months with twitch prime gun foot
has subscribed for the first time with
twitch prime as well and I very much
appreciate that
Jane womanpower says via super chat
students are punished for wanting an
education eutychus says Trump 2020 I
hope that was worth five bucks to you
skeptical sloth says Trump will bring up
Biden's dementia it's best to point out
how unelectable Biden is in
every way before he wins the primary and
is destroyed by Trump it's very very
interesting
I missed a bunch of super chats before
let me see if I can catch them up
Justin rossmann says amuse my fantasy
for a moment any chance seniors
uncharacteristically stay home tomorrow
for fear of the coul virus whereas
younger Bernie voters would be less
scared and too passionate to not vote be
nice I find it incredibly unlikely I I
think is an incredibly unlikely outcome
Marika says what would you say to Warren
supporters thinking about voting Biden
just because of electability I know a
few listen and no matter what I say
Warren supporters are going to be very
much split between Biden and Bernie and
I don't think the electability issue is
is that the main one Vaughn hunter says
if Trump were to win how much does it
hurt or helped the progressive wing of
the Democrats I said earlier I believe
if if Trump defeats Biden it's probably
good for the progressive movement for
2024 and 2022 even potentially I would I
would even suggest let me say thank you
to grid sleep who has signed up via
patreon I appreciate that very much
let's see some other Super chats we
addressed my throat issue I do have a
tickle in my throat don't want anybody
to be angry about that I may you know I
was I was today on the program I
mentioned it's not even conceivable that
I had coronavirus ten days ago I had a
few days of a very mild dry cough which
is an 85 percent prevalence with
coronavirus I think it's very likely
that the denominator is absolutely
gigantic when it comes to kovat 19 and I
if once they get the tests widely out
there if I took it and I tested positive
for antibodies or or what I wouldn't be
shocked if somebody said David you had
coronavirus ten days ago I think there
are probably thousands or tens of
thousands of people who did or will soon
have it a lot of extremely mild cases
and we already
talked about that a bunch a bunch
earlier today
Zachary Monroe says I skipped the
question alright let me see if I can
find it
Zachary Monroe let's see I'm assuming
Fox News has twisted all information
regarding the virus and the stock market
to push their political agenda what are
your thoughts I don't know if they have
I mean I mean I just I just don't know
watching a fox news - no Zachary but
there's no doubt that some of that is
being done by the president and if
that's the case then Fox News is
probably doing a bunch of it as well I
think I have now gotten your latest
question
Zachary Maxx asks what's the path
forward for progressives in the next
five years let's focus on some Senate
races for 2020 and then getting the
Senate back in 2022 before we think so
long term the god-emperor says who could
continue the progressive movement with
the same popularity integrity likability
and policies after Bernie listen I think
part of the problem for Bernie is he's
not likable enough I think that's why
he's not winning I think that there is a
significant portion of the Democratic
electorate who's not interested in
Bernie Sanders and that's why despite
there only being being two candidates
now what you see in the national polls
is that bernie is not going any higher
than 38 or 36 percent when they said
Bernie's a ceiling sorry oh that's not
there we go when they said Bernie's
ceiling was a 20 they were wrong when
they said Bernie's ceiling was 25 they
were wrong when they said the ceiling
was 30 they were wrong but the ceiling
may be 36 or 38 and we're going to very
very quickly see in some of those
primaries tomorrow so I think that we
need to carry on the issues of Bernie
Sanders but maybe with different
candidates and I know there are many
people in my audience who agree and some
also who disagree Eutychus youtube says
totally was worth it I like and support
the show interesting points you bring up
get well a lot laud says GOP canceled
open state virginia and doubled dem
turnout resulting in buda and jumping 40
points overnight do you see North Dakota
doing the same after G
P canceled oh are you saying the
Republicans canceled their Virginia
primary it's an open state and a whole
bunch of them voted for Democrats maybe
we will see that in North Dakota I'm not
totally sure that's gonna do it today
today is a short stream I do want to say
thank you to Michele benvenuti who is
new member number 15 tonight a very much
appreciate that very long stream
tomorrow night results join me tomorrow
night
like and subscribe on YouTube follow on
Twitch grab a membership oh and Krystal
Keller also new member number 16 tonight
thanks to everybody I'll see you
tomorrow night live results it's do or
die for Bernie either he's got a shot
after tomorrow or it's over after
tomorrow we will know by midnight east